davos is expensive at the best of times
a recent surge in value by the swiss
franc means that right now it's an
especially pricey place to visit
appropriately currencies were on the
agenda at the world economic forum
especially the euro on thursday the
european central bank announced a
mountain of stimulus more than a
trillion euros worth on the same day
german chancellor angela merkel
addressed the forum she said reforms
must continue for europe to fully end
the financial crisis
it's more or less under control but it's
not over europe still hasn't won back
enough trust and it hasn't regained
enough of its competitiveness
as the digital economy plays an ever
greater role europe also needs to work
to develop its profile in the digital
world
we have to work on our marketplace
identity and develop product oriented
industries we have to figure out how to
go digital with products but also with
lots more services we haven't achieved
that yet
the global economic downturn was a topic
this year but politics and conflicts
took up more space on the agenda than
usual
the ukraine conflict the threat from
terrorism poverty and climate change
they were also on the agenda over the
past few days both in the main podium
discussions and in the smaller
discussion groups the search for answers
however is still continuing
and sunday's elections in greece may
bring yet more developments for the
world's economies to deal with